est-ce que vous croyez au fantômes oui
j'en ai eu beaucoup il est sympa il y en
a des sympas
ceux on croit vous croyez on va faire
une interview croyante
[Musique]
Paco est-ce que vous croyez en vous oui
est-ce que vous croyez en Dieu oui je
l'ai vu trois fois Harry je l'ai vu je
l'ai vu quand vous n'auriez pas les
accrédules quand j'ai eu 20 ans pendant
une partie de foot
sur la touche au stade Pershing c'était
un soleil colossal j'étais projeté là où
j'ai devant ce soleil comme ça tous les
20 ans j'ai cette privilège de le voir
et la deuxième fois la deuxième fois
c'était une immense spirale rouge était
dans un taxi bloqué place de la Concorde
et j'ai entendu cette voix qui me disait
veux-tu me voir encore j'ai dit oui mais
c'était c'était toujours j'arrive à
placer la Concorde
et moi j'ai dit oui mais à l'intérieur
sauf que le chauffeur de taxi de taxi
n'entendent rien et
je parle avec Dieu
et j'étais proche j'étais pas de
sacrilège vous allez avoir des pépins
dans votre vie
si il fait le signe de la croix
en tout cas je mise là-dessus il est oui
oui oui très juste et c'était une
immense spirale rouge vie et ma prise
que la vie la spirale la chaleur et m'a
pris des tas de trucs et la troisième
fois c'était dans une voiture roulée
cette fois-ci on n'est pas arrêté et en
voiture et il m'a appris il m'a montré
un immense jusqu'à l'infini il y avait
des perles rose dorées comme ça qui
s'étonnait à l'infini il m'a dit vous
les humains vous pensez que votre
continuum espace temps est la seule
chose que j'ai créé mais je crée depuis
l'infini jusqu'à l'éternité et voilà ton
monde est un de ces mondes il a montré
une boule comme ça un petit mot espace
temps un moment j'ai vu une explosé
un bang Bing et puis après notre Bing se
réaliser des et c'était le Big Bang tu
vas avoir les pièces emmerdement
non je ris pas de toi j'aime bien vous
avez le droit de vous [__] de ma
gueule
ça fait peur fais pas les gros yeux mais
ne faites pas ne faisait pas est-ce que
vous est-ce que vous suivez là est-ce
que vous même moi j'ai du mal mais je
pense à aucun moment qui se moque de
Monsieur rabat mais je pense comme nous
non je me dis pas moqué de Dieu on peut
le revoir les images
comme nous n'avons pas eu la chance
d'avoir vécu cette expérience dans une
taxi en place
on a le droit de se renseigner quand
même bien sûr bien sûr taco est-ce que
vous croyez c'est une reine anglaise une
reine anglaise
est-ce que vous croyez que les femmes
simulent parfois
je pense que oui parfois parfois
rarement mais parfois est-ce que vous
croyez au trèfle aux pattes de lapin
touche du bois tout ça vous croyez pas
vous croyez aux anges gardiens oui
les extraterrestres j'en ai vu ah bon
on essaye
des gens qui passent qui traversent la
vie en regardant leurs chaussures ou le
sol c'est toujours les gens tous les
gens qui ont des problèmes de fric ou
des problèmes de mal d'être regardent
toujours le solver vérifier les gens
dans la rue et il y a les autres les
poètes il est là qui regardent le ciel
et quand vous relevez le regard vers le
ciel vous voyez des choses auxquelles
pour un poteau il y a deux possibilités
la créature de Roswell c'est une vraie
ah oui mais on le sait ça parce que
allez pas à l'époque il y a eu mais
pourquoi pourquoi
comme par hasard avec
Rockefeller ont-ils créé la CIA comme
par hasard en 47 tout de suite après le
crash de Roswell on est con donc Pradel
avait raison oui il existe Pradel je
n'ai vu à la télé est-ce que vous croyez
au marabout non au bout de ficelle un
astrologie on joue pas personnellement
oui qu'en effet quand tu fais par des
gens sérieux par exemple Françoise Hardy
le fait très bien très bien vous êtes de
quel signe vous Verseau
comme Mozart
ah je sais pas mais en même temps comme
Giscard
c'est lequel qui joue de la musique
oui j'en ai eu beaucoup mais sympa il y
en a des sympas ils sont tous sympas il
y en a qui sont bloqués c'est vrai
qu'ils sont bloqués
au moment où vous mourrez ils aiment
tellement la vie ils s'accroche à la vie
donc il se décatage pas du corps et il
s'accroche au meubles au lieu et ma
nièce qui a 5 ans on a vu comme moi mais
il y a plusieurs j'avais un château de
Château de Palio
[Musique]
est-ce que vous croyez au journal
télévisé je suis fervent que je suis là
le zappeur le plus invraisemblable qui
soit est-ce que vous croyez à l'effet
des crèmes anti-rides
plus dur déjà non mes sœurs ont comme
moi une peau par idée parce que notre
grand-mère nous avait appris à nous
laver sans savon jamais jamais de savon
à l'eau chaude l'eau bouillante
le gant de toilette trempé dans le
bouillon que vous passez sur le visage
jamais de savon mes sœurs n'ont pas une
ride elles ont plus de peau non plus
elles sont magnifiques
qui maintient la peau
et oui oui j'en connais beaucoup
mes sœurs par exemple combien de temps
ressort
marié donc ça fait quoi ça fait déjà 45
ans 45 ans sans baiser ailleurs non se
sont mariés vierges elles étaient
vierges n'avaient pas touché un garçon
j'ai mon ange gardien qui m'envoie un
texto là
merci beaucoup vous êtes au top amitié
sincère Lolo Boyer merci mon Lolo
alors est-ce que vous croyez au sexe
sans amour
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui ça
s'appelle la baise ah bon et c'est ça
oui
on fait de l'amour avec la femme que
l'on aime et on baise les filles de
rencontres c'est totalement différent et
c'était donc c'est un sexe sans amour
moi je comprends pas pourquoi on vous
file pas le ministère de l'éducation
nationale
est-ce que vous croyez par exemple que
l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur l'argent
peut être la chose la plus dangereuse
exemple le loto avec ces sommes
insensées et combien de gens se sont
suicidés par ce qu'ils ont eu trop de
fric et ils n'ont pas su gérer cet
argent il y a quand même beaucoup plus
de gens qui se sont suicidés parce
qu'ils en avaient pas si on voit
les chiffres je crois pas ça vous croyez
que les drogues douces conduisent
forcément en drogues dures
obligatoirement j'en ai trop connu je
suis quand même une génération qui a vu
naître toutes les drogues tous les
années 70 au tout les drogues le LSD est
arrivé Mike Brant qui se lance dans dans
le sud sa terrasse en croyant qui était
un oiseau et tous les mecs qui me
disaient aujourd'hui pas ça oh moi
j'arrêterai quand je voudrais on les
retrouvait mort d'une overdose dans les
chiottes de l'Alcazar non non ils ont
commencé par des choses douces ils ont
été affinés par les drogues dures et ils
sont donc pas du tout
un verre est-ce que vous croyez à
l'innocence de Michael Jackson
non non c'est-à-dire arriver à une telle
grande gloire
il ne sait plus où le moral s'arrête
doit s'arrêter c'est à dire pour lui
étant de Michael Jackson c'est-à-dire un
dieu vivant la plus de repère et donc il
croit qu'il peut faire tout ce qu'il
veut que personne ne le reprochera
jamais rien
est-ce que vous croyez si je vous dis
que je vous crois
vous passez pour un être un peu
démoniaque dans le sens dans le sens
simplement que vous avez un verbe assez
terrifiant que vous savez un peu
déshabiller l'âme des gens et mais au
fond de vous-même il y a un
c'est ça doit venir d'une d'un atavisme
racial il y a un être qui a vécu
beaucoup de choses et par vos
réincarnations vous avez
une personnalité extraordinaire dans le
passé c'était quoi avant les j'étais
j'ai eu deux au moins deux vies que je
connais il y en a une où j'étais un
galérien je ramène sur une galère
c'était horrible dans l'Antiquité
gréco-romaine et une autre vie au
moyen-âge où j'attaque un château fort
et je prends un boulet dans le ventre
j'en suis persuadé
rien à voir et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu